امام المحكمه الفيدراليه في قضيه احتفاضه
بوتائق السريه من ارشيد البيت الابيض
واعتبر ترامب الذي عين فريق دفاع جديد بعد
تقديم فريق محاميه استقالاتهم اعتبر
الخطوه محاوله من اداره بايدن لاستبعاده
من انتخابات الرئاسه المقبله
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كندا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما مدى وجهه اتهام ترامب
اداره بايدن بمحاوله قطع الطريق امام
عودته الى الرئاسه من خلال توجيه تهم
فيدراليه اليه وما دلاله تغييره فريق
محاميه قبل ثلاثه ايام فقط من بطوله امام
المحكمه وما مدى تاثير التعم التي يواجهها
ترامب على امكانيه ترشحه للانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله وحضوره في تلك
الانتخابات في حاله البراءه او الادانه
وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان تنعكس هذه القضيه على
خارطه مرشحي الحزب الجمهوري للرئاسه
المقبله وما موقف
الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطينيه
[موسيقى]
لاول مره في تاريخ الولايات المتحده يمثل
فيها رئيس امريكا سابق امام محكمه
فيدراليه اعلن الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب انه سوف يواجه امام المحكمه
الفيدراليه في ميامي يوم الثلاثاء المقبل
على خلفيه لائحه اتهام وجهت اليه في اطار
قضيه احتفاظه بوثائق سريه من ارشيف البيت
الابيض بعد مغادرته منصبه القضيه التي
وجهت هيئه محلفين كبرى تهمه فيها الى
ترامب تضم السبعهم من بينها التامر وحيازه
وثائق السريه وعرقله العداله وانتهاك
قانون التجسس وفيما بدا خطوه مربكه
للمتابعين افادت وسائل اعلام بان فريق
دفاع ترامب قدم استقالته وان ترامب عينه
فريق محامين جدد قبل ثلاثه ايام فقط من
مثوله امام
وفي مقابل تاكيد الرئيس جو بايدن عدم
وصلته باي قضيه تخص ترامب وتاكيد البيت
الابيض ذلك ورفضه التعليق على القضيه التي
واجهها ترامب يصر الاخير على ان قضيئ
القضيه هي قضيه سياسيه بامتياز وان الهدف
منها هو قطع الطريق امام
وصوله للرئاسه
كيف هم يلاحقونني لاننا نتقدم الان في
استطلاعات الراي بفرق كبير على بايدن
والمرشحين الجمهوريين والطريقه الوحيده
لايقافه هي استخدام هذه الحرب ولا يمكننا
السماح بذلك بلادنا في طريقها الى الجحيم
وبعد نهايه ولايته قاموا باستخدام وزاره
العدل ومكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي كسلاح لا
يمكننا السماح باستمرار ذلك لان بلادنا
تتفتت نواجه مشاكل كبيره وقضيه ليست واحده
منها
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من واشنطن
الصحفي والكاتب السياسي في مجله نيوزك
وتنضم الينا الدكتوره ميلان المستشاره
السابقه في اللجنه القضائيه لمجلس النواب
الامريكي
وينضم الينا ايضا الدكتور محمد المنشاوي
الكاتب الصحفي المختص في الشان الامريكي
اهلا بكم جميعا وقدمها
لنبدا بالتطور الاخير تغيير فريق الدفاع
عن الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب ما دلاله
هذا الاجراء الاستغناء عن الفريق الاول او
اقالته واستبدال بفريق دفاع جديد
هناك احتمالات متعدده لتفسير هذا الامر قد
يكون هناك اختلاف في وجهات النظر حول
الاستراتيجيه الواجب ان تعتمد او تضارب في
الشخصيات قد يكون
الثقه بمحاميه لربما شعر الرئيس ترامب
انهم ليسوا افضل المحامين امام المحكمه
الفدراليه حيث اننا نتحدث عن مرحله جديده
وقد يفكر المرء ان القانون الذي يرعى
مساله احتفاضه
بوثائق سريه هذا الامر بسيط سواء كان
للرئيس ام لا ولكن نحن نعرف ان الرئيس
بايدن احتفظ بوثائق سريه والسيد اوباما
واعتقد ايضا السيد
احتفظ بوثائق مماثله وايضا السيده كلينتن
سمحت
بتعامل مع هذه الوثائق السريع بطريقه غير
قانونيه ما من احد منهم تم توجيه لائحه
اتحاد اليه وبالتالي هناك وجه سياسي وهذا
ما يسلط الضوء عليه السيد ترامب لربما
الفريق الدفاعي القديم قد يكون لديه راي
مخالف ولكن انا فقد اخمن انا لا اعرف
بالضبط سبب هذا التغيير
شلون قبل ان ندخل في موضوع التسيس اسالك
نفس السؤال قراءتك فيه هذا الاجراء هل
يبدو عاديا ام ان القضيه ربما بدت او تبدو
خاسره من الان كي يستغني عنهم الرئيس
ترامبوا يغير فريق الدفاع ام ان وضعه
القانون معقد يعني ثلاثه ايام فقط بقيت
على المثول امام المحكمه
ان موقفه القانوني معقد للغايه والرئيس
سيد ترامب قد استبدل محاميه عده مرات
ونعرف انه لا يدفع اجورهم وهذه مشكله اخرى
توجه السيد ترامب من الصعب معرفه
بالاعتماد على ما قاله الضيف الاخر لماذا
قام بتغييره وبالتالي انهم لا يعطون اي
تصريحات اعلاميه
اعتقد اننا نعرف المزيد عندما يكون هناك
فريق جديد قانوني جديد للسيد ترامبو
رئيس هذا الفريق هو الذي نفسه الذي
استخدمه في قضيه نيويورك بالتالي نعرف ما
الذي سيقوله هذا المحامي قد تتوقع انه
ربما قد يكون حاضرا معه يوم الثلاثاء
بصحبه محامين اخر
ذلك هل تبدو قضيه معقده جدا الى هذا الحد
لا اعتقد ان قضيه معقده وزاره العدل نجحت
في ان تقنع هيئه المحلفين بتوجيه
الاتهامات الى الرئيس ترامبو وهذه في هذه
الحلقه يتم توجيه اتهامات اذا كان هناك
دلائل وقرائن تدعم الحكم ضد هذا المتهم
وهو الرئيس ترامب في هذه الحاله لكن
القضيه قد تكون معقده من ناحيه اخرى
اجرائيه ان القاضيه التي ستنظر في هذه
القضيه ويوقف امامها الرئيس ترامب متهما
يوم الثلاثاء هي قضيه اعيانها الرئيس
ترامب ذاته عام 20 عام 2020 القضيه ايلين
كونور وهي صغيره في السن 42 عاما من اصول
كوبيه جمهوريه تبرعت كثيرا للحزب الجمهوري
فاعتقد ان هذا سيضيف الكثير من الاثاره
على هذه القضيه التاريخيه بالاساس هنا نجد
الولايات المتحده ضد الرئيس ضد دونالد
ترامب القضيه الاولى منذ شهرين في نيويورك
كانت ولايه نيويورك ضد
هنا القضيه تتعلق بالولايات المتحده كدوله
كامله ضد شخص هو الرئيس وليس كاولايه مثل
حاله نيويورك السابقه اعود اليك
وقبل قليل كنت تقول ان
غيره فعلوا اكثر من ذلك ولم يحدث معهم ما
يحدث مع ترامب من احاله الى القضاء لكن
الا ترى ان التهم
الموجهه اليه التامر حيازه وثائق سريه
عرقله العداله انتهاك قانون التجسس هذه
تهم لا تدل على ما قلته قبل قليل من ان
الموضوع
مسيس من اجل عرقلته من الوصول الى الى
الدخول الانتخابات الرئاسه
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان تهم المرتبطه بعرقله سير العداله
غالبا ما تكون سياسيه
تهم التامر نفس الشيء الجهود تهدف الى
منعي دونالد ترامب من الدخول في السباق
الرئاسي ونحن دخلنا
بقوه في المساحه القانونيه الايه الى
تحقيق هذا الهدف
الجمهوريون قاموا بشيء مماثل في وجه
بالكلينتن في خلال رئاسته نحن نعرف وبناء
على التقارير الوارده ان اداره اوباما
والمسؤولين في اداره اوباما كانوا يعرفون
عن التفاصيل المرتبطه بخطه حمله
لاستخدام الوثائق في وجه ترامب يعرفون ان
المشتبه بهم
الاول ان المشتبه لم يكن هناك دلائل تؤدي
الى هذه الادانه ولكن اختاروا ان يستخدموا
هذه الحجج نحن نتحدث عن عمليه سياسيه لدي
قلق عندما استمع الى السيد بايدن الذي قال
انه لم يتدخل بهذا القرار المرتبط بتوجيه
الاتهام او لائحه الاتهام الى السيد ترامب
نحن نتحدث عن قضيه في غايه الخطوره بالنظر
الى الاشخاص المشاركين فيها والتهم التي
نتحدث عنها واعتقد ان هذا النوع من
القرارات يجب ان يتخذ من قبل رئيس
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وليس وزاره
العدل ولا النيابه العامه
بهذا الكلام قضيه مسيسه مئه بالمئه يقول
اعتقد انما قاله بيتر هو اكثر الاشياء
سخفا ما سمعتها اذا ما كان الرئيس بايدن
مساهما باي طريقه ما باتخاذها للقرار
لربما بيتر
سيكون منتقدا للرئيس في تدخله في هذه
العمليه القانونيه هذه هي الطريقه التي
يعمل بها النظام لدينا القضائي الرئاسه
منفصله تماما عن النظام القضائي والنظام
القضائي او وزاره العدل هي تتخذ قراراتها
بشكل مستقيل القضيه ضد السيد ترامبا راينا
مؤخرا
تسجيلا صوتيا تحدث فيه كيف ان كان بحوزته
معلومات سريه ويعرف انها معلومات سريه
وكان يتحدث عنها بشكل واضح في الغرفه
اعتقد انها هذا سيكون دليلا قويا ضده ومن
الواضح ان السيده ترامب قد حاول ان يعيق
العداله عن طريق الكذب على المحققين ام
مجرى الامور ولقد راينا
كبار مساعدي الرئيس ترامب قدم توجيهه هم
لهم وايضا هنالك ايضا نتوقع بوجودي تهمه
التامر قد يكون هنالك تهم اضافي هذه
القضيه ستكون قضيه كبيره هذا الامر هي
ليست القضيه الاولى ضد الرئيس
فيما يتعلق
بالدفع الدفعات لنجمه اباحيه السابقه
وايضا ستتوقع ان نتوقع ان نرى تهمه اضافيه
في جورجيا حول جهد من اجل ان يكون هنالك
جذب للاصوات في ولايه جورجيا وايضا قضيه
مساله الاحداث في السادس من يناير وجاكس
ماث في وزاره العدل ما يزال يتحرى ويحقق
فيها بالتالي فان الضغوط القضائيه على
الرئيس السابق ترامب تزداد لا اعتقد ان
الرئيس بايدن تدخل بهذا الامر باي طريقه
من السيده ترامب هو ليس فوق القانون ويبدو
ان معظم مناصريه يعتقدون ان القانون لا
يجب ان يطبق على سيد ترامبث مشاوي لو اخذت
التوصيف الذي وصف به القضيه
بيت يقول هذه القضيه في غايه الخطوره هل
هذا يعني انه يمكن ان تكون لها ربما
تداعيات على مستوى الشارع ربما الناس تفقد
ثقتها في العداله الامريكيه هل هناك اي
تداعيات محتمل لها
بالطبع القضيه شديتها الخطوره وهناك على
الاقل
ثلث الجمهوريين يدعمون بشده الرئيس ترامب
ورئيس السابق ترامبو
ويوافقون على كل ما يقوله ان هناك مؤامره
ضده لكن انا اختلف
بشده مع بيتر في ان الرئيس بايدن او
الاداره الامريكيه الديمقراطيه تريد
الازاحه او الاطاحه من خارج المنافسه في
المنافسه الانتخابيه اعتقد ان
يحلم ان يواجه ترامب في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه فهو المنافس الاكثر
الاكثر ضعفا بين الجمهورين اذا نفس الرئيس
بايدن ديسانتوس حكم فلوريدا هو يصغره ب 40
عاما وسيكشف ضعف الرئيس بايدن بشده وكبره
الكبير في السن وما يترتب على ذلك لكن
الرئيس السابق ترامب له سجل سيء في الحكم
واعتقد ان قرب سنه من سن رئيس بايدن سي من
سن بايدن ليس قضيه كبيره في الانتخابات
وهذا ما يحلم به الديمقراطيون الادانه
لترامب سترفع شعبيته كما حدث قبل شهرين في
حاله نيويورك وهو يتقدم الان الصفوف
المرشحين الجمهوريين واعتقد ان كل ما يحدث
من متاعب قانونيه له ستدعم ترشيحه
على بطاقه الحزب الجمهوري وهو ما لا يريده
ما يريده الحزب الديمقراطي فاعتقد ان
الديمقراطيون هذه الاخبار اخبار ادانت
ترامب خبر سيء لهم وليس كما يدعي بيتر
انها خبر جيدن يعني
كانت الناس
يعني ستخدمه لانها سترفع من شعبياتها ليس
كذلك
يصغر فقط عامين عن بايدن وهي القضيه
الكبرى عند النخوه الامريكي سن الرئيس
بايدن واليوقته الذهنيه فاذا كان ينافسه
شخص مثل ترامب يصغره بعامين فقط فلن تكون
قضيه كبيره لكن اذا كان ينافسه شخص
كحاكم ولاد في الورده راندي سانتوس يصغره
باربعين عاما ستكون قضايا كبيره
للديمقراطيين
يعني اذا كان يعني ترامب كما يقول الاستاذ
محمد مشاوي هو المرشح الاقل حظا او الاكثر
ضعفا بين
مرشحي داخل الحزب الجمهوري هنا نسال عن
تاثير هذه القضيه اذا في خارطه مرشحي
الحزب الجمهوري للانتخابات
هل ستتاثر
في البدايه انا لم ارى اي استطلاعات لراي
تشير الى ان الرئيس السابق ترامب هو
الاضعف لقد شاهدت استطلاعات للراي تشير
الى ان السيد ترامب يكسب على السيد بايدن
اخذين بعين الاعتبار هامش الخطا في هذه
الاحصائيات حتى مع ذلك الرئيس السابق
ترامبياكس اعتقد ان دونالد ترامبور هو
مرشح قوي قد لا يكون مرشح المفضل او قد
يكونوا مرشحي المفضل ولكن اعتقد ان هذه
القضيه تعود بنا الى مساله
المسائله والمحاسبه انا لا اتفق مع
الدكتوره سلوان وانا لدي قلق ازاءه موضوع
وزاره العدل لا تكون خاضعه لرئاسه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي جزء من
الاداره التنفيذيه او التنفيذيه الرئيس
بايدن ليس بالضروره ان يكون طرفا في ذلك
ولكن يجب التواصل معه واستشارته بالنسبه
الى موضوع خطر في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حيث ان الرئيس ترامب هو رئيس
سابق والرئيس بايدن من مسؤوليته ان يحافظ
على مكتب البيت الابيض المكتب الرئاسي في
البيت الابيض واذا ما دخلنا في هذه الحلقه
اذا ما خسر بايدن بايدن توجه اليه لائحه
اتهام ويستمر الامر على ما هو عليه هذا
غير صحي للولايات المتحده الامريكيه نحن
نتحدث عن اتهامات وجهت الى السيد ترامبلا
ربما كان بحوزته وثائق سريه ما كان يتوجب
عليه ان يحتفظ بها يمكنه ان يقول
كالرئيس باستطاعه ان ارفع السريه
اذا بالنسبه الى سياسيين اخرين قاموا بنفس
الارتكابات سمح لهم
بان يستمروا في حياتهم السياسيه من دون اي
عمليه قضائيه هذا يعني ان القضاء منحاز
انت تقارن منذ بدايه البرنامج تقصد من
تحديدا
نعم
تقصد من بان هناك من فعل اكثر مما يفعلها
وفعلها ولكن لم يحاكموا ولم يحاسبوا من
مجددا السيد
كان لديه وثائق سريه نسي انها كانت بحوزته
كانت في المراه في منزله في دلوور
بالاضافه الى جامعه بنسلفانيا ايضا الرئيس
الصادق اوباما نائب رئيس الصادق نعود ايضا
لوزيره الخارجيه كلينتن التي يمكن ان تقول
ان لديها صلاحيه لان ترفع السريع ولكنها
كانت تسيء استخدام هذه الوثائق اذا في هذا
المنصب هناك احاطه تقدم للمسؤولين حول ما
هي الامور التي يمكن ان تقوم بها السيده
الوزيره وما يمكن او ما يجب الا تقوم به
وبالتالي هذه رساله
يركز عليها السيد ترامب بان هناك قضاء
منحاز وكان بعض الاشخاص يحصلون على غرامات
لانهم
قادوا بسرعه مرتفعه السياره من دون اشخاص
اخرين وهذه هي الامور التي يتطرق اليها
السيد هي مساله سياسيه
الحزب الديمقراطي كيف يتابع هذه القضيه
ومالاتها هل يفكر في استثمارها سياسيا
لصالحه لكسب مكاسب سياسيه من وراء القضيه
اعتقد اننا سنرى الديمقراطيه يقومون
بالكثير السيد ترامبا سيضر بنفسه
وبالتاكيد هنالك سرك اعلامي حول حول التهم
ايضا المحاكمه والقضيه القادمه في نيويورك
والقضيه في جورجيا اعتقد ان الكثير من
المصوطين المستقلين
يشعرون سيغيرون رايهم كمرشح للانتخابات
حتى والعنه انصارهم متجمعون حوله وهم
يقومون بتسجيل فيديوهات دعما له يقومون
بالتبرع له لكن هنالك الكثير من الذين
سائموا من هذا السرك ولا يريدون ان يكون
لهم مرشح
يخضع لتحقيق بالتالي من هذا المنظور
بالتاكيد
مراقبه هذا الامر
سيتعب الكثير من ربما الكثير من الذين
الذين مرشحين من قبل الحزب الجمهوريه
القلقين من ربما جذب لسيده ترامب للكثير
من الاهتمام في هذه الحمله ايضا سيكون
هنالك وضع غير طبيعي لشخص متهم بهذه التهم
الجنائيه وهو يحتل بهذا
المنصب المهم في داخل الحزب الجمهوري واني
هنالك احتماليه لانتخابه لكي يكون رئيس
المستقبلين للولايات المتحده شكرا جزيلا
لك يا دكتوره ميلاني المستشاره السابقه في
اللجنه القضائيه لمجلس النواب الامريكي
ونشكر ايضا ضيفنا منه
الصحفي والكاتب السياسي في مجلات
وشكرا لضيفنا انحاء الدكتور محمد المنشاوي
الكاتبه الصحفي المختص بشان الامريكي شكرا
لكم جميعا
لا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]